la transformation du visage de nos cités
semblent être le caractère dominant de
la seconde moitié du siècle le quartier
latin lui-même à à changer de
personnalité et l'étudiant des années 30
en pèlerinage aux sources aurait peine à
reconnaître le boul mich de ses 20 ans
et plus solides bastions n'ont pas
résisté aux assauts d'une évolution un
platane
même les établissements dont la présence
en ces lieux paraît logique sont
directement menacés par la double
offensive de la chaussure et de
l'habillement le boul mich est en pleine
évolution le quartier latin eric de
moins en moins son nom
certes la sorbonne est toujours là mais
la terminologie ne sauve que les
apparences les pôles d'attraction
estudiantin en bout c'est vers l'ouest
les carrefours mabillon et de l'odéon
ont pris la relève de la halle aux vins
à la chambre des députés le boulevard
saint germain est devenu l' axe
principal du paris université
saint germain des prés aussi a changé il
y a quinze ans jean paul sartre y
régnait avec simone de beauvoir le
quartier rit s'amuse gréco mais depuis
cette époque juliette gréco a changé de
profil et le café de flore de clientèle
il ya 15 ans pas d'effet était leur père
d'une espèce indéfinissable les
existentialistes une femme qui vivait
dans les cars affectionner l'hermétisme
intellectuelle et affichait un souverain
mépris pour les apparence extérieure la
mode devait durer plusieurs années
aujourd'hui à saint germain des prés la
clientèle ne fait que passer elle vient
le plus souvent d'auteuil et de la
muette le complète issue anglais et la
robe de soie ont tendance à remplacer le
blood j
le décor aussi a fait des concessions
des nouveaux établissements ne se
veulent plus intellectuel mais
fonctionnel
soyons justes la décoration conçu par
slavik dans le style 1900 donne à
l'ensemble une personnalité
incontestable du 1er janvier à la saint
sylvestre et jusqu'à 2 heures du matin
on y trouve à peu près tout ce qu'on
veut
rares témoins d'une époque révolue
l'épicerie depuis 15 ans elle n'a guère
changé la frite et les conserves ils
sont la providence d'une clientèle
fidèle à travers les générations
seule nouveauté les attractions
spontanée
ap
ambiance joyeuse aussi aux assassins
les danses également évolué il ya 15 ans
c'était la folie du rhin
aujourd'hui dans les caves de
saint-germain-des-prés
l'ambiance est celle de la plus correcte
des surboum les danses sont devenues
plus sophistiquées
signe des temps il y à moi de bohème à
saint germain des prés il n'y a presque
plus que des étudiants des presque vrai